hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
there's a long discussion of diversions
or distractions never sees a mall in
French in Blaise Pascal's passe and he
tells us some very important things
about why it is that people seek out
distractions and and what role they play
and he positions them ultimately between
what we can call the the final ends for
human beings happiness and unhappiness
or misery where do all the distractions
that we busy ourselves with that we
occupy our lives with that we fritter
away time on that we pursue for the sake
of funner or wealth or so many other
things where do these fit in are they
part of happiness are they necessary for
it are they on the other hand something
that leads to misery or are they a hedge
against misery this is a set of really
important questions and POSCO all begins
you know with some general assumptions
in the background that human beings
actually do desire happiness however
they conceived of it and to avoid
unhappiness or misery museu in his
french so the question then is would
diversions whether we conceive of them
in terms of the activities themselves or
of the objects that they're aimed at or
that we might win through them do they
really make us happy and it seems like
the answer to that the no-brainer in
Pascal's own time and in our own time is
well yes otherwise people wouldn't be
spending all this money and time and
attention on these things so you know
we'll look at some examples from his own
time to think of some from our time
sports you know when people go to see
their team play in a game that may be
you know one of a hundred games they'll
play this season or you know in some
cases less much less than that
and they want to see their team win and
play well and go to the championship and
the decisions of the referees go for
them and shear and all that sort of
stuff are they are they making
themselves happy and you could ask well
why are you there at the tailgate party
man because I love this sort of thing
this is what life is all about that's
what some people would say and they can
rattle off all these sports statistics
and get into arguments about you know
whether this person should be drafted or
not or purchased or however else that's
going on whether the coach is doing a
good job and pretty soon the whole day
is gone
I know people who spend their entire
weekends frittering it away moving from
one sports game to the next we can think
of many other examples what about games
that other people play where they're
more actively engaged in it because
they're playing a massive online
computer game with other people maybe
one where they're shooting things up or
there's a role-playing element involved
well you know you can spend a lot of
time doing that and there is some
engagement and you win some stuff in it
don't you
metals or prizes but they're all ilusory
any sort of board games I like that
aren't they any sort of role-playing
games are like that what about things
that are more serious things that are
not just about games they may involve
some game playing what about
relationships you know getting out there
dating pursuing whatever you know object
of your affection happens to suit you
maybe even though the whole discovery of
where do I fit in on the spectrum right
all of that or reading the most books or
anything you like being a hobbyist
collecting all sorts of things getting
the most likes in social media these are
all ways in which we divert ourselves do
these really make us happy he gives you
some other
cool examples he loves the hunting
example people chase after hares and you
can think about all the stuff that goes
into hunting you know if you know any
hunters or know any fisherman you know
that people can spend hours and hours
not just in the activity but the prep
for the activity and then talking about
it afterwards he also talks about a
person going to sea or or besieging a
town commissioning you know themselves
in in the army all sorts of other things
along these lines why do we want
diversions really really make us happy
another key idea that's coming up here
as well in terms of happiness what do we
conceive of happiness is being do we
conceive of it as a state of rest where
we've got what it is that we were
looking for or do we think of it as a
state of excitement a state of ongoing
activity think about people who their
main form of diet you know diversion is
sexual relations with other is it is it
about being in bed and engaging in all
the activities is it about the lead up
to it is it about the bragging rights or
whatever happens to be the case
afterwards I don't writing some some
sort of letter or you know documenting
things in some way what is it that
people are really after here and why are
they after it excitement in what now
Pascale tells us that the reason why we
both seek out diversions and don't
really understand why we're doing it why
we spend so much time on them is because
we don't understand the human condition
adequately we've concealed it from
ourselves and that's one thing that
diversions help us to do what is our
real human condition there's good points
to it but there are also some bad points
he says that we exist in a state of what
he calls natural poverty we are not as
good as we
we are not as smart as we think we are
not as well off as we think in many
different ways says there's one real
reason the natural poverty of our feeble
and mortal condition so miserable that
nothing can comfort us when we think of
it closely when we think of it closely
that requires a sort of concentration
that requires putting the diversions
aside that requires not answering the
phone not answering the texts not
turning to the social media and clicking
and finding out what what the latest
scandal is or what the latest puppy
picture is or any of those sorts of
things
it requires sitting for a little bit and
this is this passage has got one of the
most famous lines by Pascal he says when
I have occasionally set myself to
consider the different distractions of
men the pains and perils to which they
expose themselves at court or in war
whence arise so many quarrels passions
bold and often bad ventures I have
discovered all the unhappiness of human
beings arises from one single fact that
they cannot stay quietly in their own
room that a person cannot be just by him
or herself with their own thoughts they
need other things they need distractions
so diversions or distractions they help
to take our minds off of this praat this
is this condition and they promised us
that in some way we're going to enjoy
some happiness and after a while we do
enough of this they become a need or
they even become a habit a second nature
for ourselves there are certain people
who cannot focus more than a few minutes
and take their mind away from their
phone or from golf or from you know the
latest news about the cooking world or
gossiping about other things
so another thing that he says is and
this is a very interesting point and we
don't have a lot of kings around these
days but you can think about all the
other people who have some degree of
power he says the people who you think
are enjoying the best life they need
people to provide them with diversions
so he says right here royalty is the
finest position in the world when we
imagine a king attended by every
pleasure he can feel if he be without
diversion and being left to consider and
reflect on what he is this feeble
happiness will not sustain him he will
necessarily fall into foreboding of
dangers of revolutions which may happen
finally of death and inevitable disease
you're gonna think about things as they
could actually happen so that if he be
with what is called the diversion he is
unhappy and more unhappy than the least
of his subjects who plays and diverts
himself so the CEOs the heads of the
university they pick whatever station in
life you like that gives a sort of
privilege and priority to that person
they're not really happy to the degree
that they are happy unless they can
enjoy some diversions Paschal says he's
got a really great discussion in there
about what is it that we're actually
looking for are we looking for the
object of the diversion is that what
makes us happy or are we more happy to
be engaged in the activity he says there
are reasons why we like the chase better
than the quarry and I framed it here in
terms of the Motorhead song the chase is
better than the catch this idea that we
should constantly be striving and he
says this is all men have been able to
discover to make themselves happy these
sorts of things those who philosophize
on the matter who think men unreasonable
for spending a whole day and chasing a
hare which they would not which they
would not have bought
Garrus no our nature the hair in itself
would not screen us from the sight of
death and calamities the the natural
human condition but the chase which
turns away our attention from these does
screen us then he uses the example of
the King Pyrus you may know of him
because of the term pirate victory he
fought against the Romans
and in one of the battles both sides
lost so many soldiers that Pyrus said
another victory like this will ruin me
and why was pirates fighting the Romans
in the first place he was attempting
from his kingdom of Epirus in what is
nowadays you know the Balkans area he
wanted to establish an empire like that
of his prey you know not predecessor but
because he wasn't related to him
directly but somebody who he idealized
Alexander the Great now somebody pointed
out to Pyrus well after you've made all
these conquests what are you gonna do he
said well I'm gonna sit at home and
drink wine with my friends and enjoy
myself and this guy said why the hell
don't you do that right now what's
preventing you from doing it and what it
what was it he wanted the chase he
wanted the excitement the activity and
says as men who naturally understand
their own condition avoid nothing so
much as rest there's nothing they would
leave undone and seeking turmoil not
that they have an instinctive knowledge
of true happiness so we're wrong to
blame them he's not trying to criticize
here he's trying to point out a problem
that we might get away from their error
does not lie in seeking excitement if
they seek it only as a diversion the
evil is that they seek it as if the
possession of the objects of their quest
would really make them happy it's really
about the quest itself and not about the
object of it so he says in this respect
it's right to call their quest a vain
one he also has a really great example
here this drives this point home about
diversions
in its a thought experiment imagine that
you have a person and every day he's
given a certain amount of money and he
has two or other resources and he has to
use that in some sort of contest some
sort of gambling says a man spends his
life without weariness and playing every
day for a small stake now let's change
the conditions a little bit give him
each morning the money he can win each
day on condition he does not play make
it a guarantee no longer require him to
gamble no longer require him to take a
chance no longer require him to exercise
some thought or to put something of
himself in the activity he becomes bored
he becomes unhappy Pascal says okay so
it's it's the amusement of the play and
not the winnings that he's seeking let's
change the condition some more he does
have to play but now he has to play for
nothing he can't become excited over
that Paschal says and he will feel bored
so he says it's not then the amusement
alone he seeks a languid and passionless
amusement would get boring to him will
weary him he must get excited over it he
has to deceive himself by the fancy that
he will be happy to win what he would
not have as a gift or on condition of
not playing and he must make for himself
an object of passion the emotions have
to get engaged
he says they excite the passions over
his desire his anger his fear to obtain
his imagined end this again is something
that we can see many instances of all we
have to do is look around people stir
stuff up because they want that
excitement there's another remark that
that Pascal makes that is quite
interesting here and he talks about
cases where a person is grieving he says
how does it come that this man who lost
his son only a few months ago or
who in this morning was in such trouble
be through being distressed by lawsuits
and quarrels no longer thinks of them
and and we can think of all the other
things that we would say make us
miserable think about our bodies think
about our relationships think about our
prospects how is it that distractions or
diversions can completely take our mind
off of these well it's by inducing some
sort of thought that we're going to be
happy and providing just a little little
glimpse not the reality let alone the
totality but just a little glimpse of
what happiness might be and he notes
that this really does work it's
surprising that we can in fact be so
easily distracted amused excited over so
many different things the last thing
that I want to stress here is you might
say well this is all about leisure time
and what people do when they're not at
work but some of us are serious some of
us work really hard and we keep busy and
we have people coming to us and making
demands I'm I don't have time to be
watching Netflix or gambling away or
engaging in love affairs or racing cars
or pick whatever else you want right and
there is a truth to that but that can
also become a mode of distraction as
well he has this great passage here and
then there's one a little bit later he
says what is it to be Superintendent or
Chancellor first president but to be in
a condition where in from early morning
a large number of people come from all
quarters to see them so as not to leave
them an hour in the day in which they
can think of themselves the key issue
there is that the opposite of
distraction is thinking about ourselves
and our actual condition it's not having
real work as opposed to leisure time or
puttering around it's that we
I don't actually attend to who we really
are so he says when they're in disgrace
and sent back to their country houses
where they'll act neither wealth nor
servants to help them on occasion they
do not fail to be wretched and desolate
because no one prevents them from
thinking of themselves a little bit
later he goes on and he says we're
entrusted from infancy with the care of
so many different things honor property
friends even the property in honor of
our friends were overwhelmed with
business with a study of languages with
physical exercise and here's the kicker
he says we're made to understand we
cannot be helped Pappy unless our health
our honour our fortune and that of our
friends be in good condition and a
single thing wanting can make us unhappy
so we're given cares and business that
keep us busy as he says bustling around
from the break of day and Paschal
observes isn't this a weird way to make
people happy again we come back to this
issue of happiness and misery isn't it a
strange thing to give us so many things
to do to say that this will in fact make
us happy
what genuine happiness would consist in
would be in part to be alright to sit by
ourselves for an hour in our room
undisturbed with our own thoughts but so
many of us are unable to do that so
sometimes people do that through their
leisure activities their hobbies their
obsessions sometimes people do that
through work and duties and offices and
obligations but it's all distraction and
so this is worth keeping in mind what is
the distraction really providing us with
is it is it helping us escape from
misery is it really providing us with
happiness
you